Let's compare the two methods side by side.
Recall, this was my cross-correlation formulation.
This is my convolution formulation.
You will notice the big difference here.
This one, the index i minus u, j minus v.
While here we're adding it.
Plus u and j plus v.
Again, the same looping criteria that we looked at prior, which has basically
been being able to loop over the whole image in both the two dimensions.
So notice between the two formulations of cross-correlation and
convolution, there is one difference here.
There is a plus index here and a minus index here.
What does that mean?
This is, was our kernel.
We've been playing around with this kernel all the time.
Let's actually play around with it a little bit more to understand how and
what are the differences between cross-correlation and convolution.
To help me let's actually I'm going to just give you an example of
just a small three by three.
Again notice if it's a three by three,
the neighborhood is basically k is equal to 1.
So now let's look at this formulation here.
k is equal to 1.
Remember, this one is an element that has indices 0 and 0 in two dimensions.
The first element we will be basically doing is i minus, 1,
so this is the index minus 1 by minus 1.
And similarly as I'm looping through it,
you would notice that this would be 0 minus 1, then of course,.
This would be 1 and minus 1.
Traversing through this way, this you pretty much know the answer for
this one is 1 and 1, and this would be minus 1 and 1.
So notice this is how we loop around, so
in essence when I did cross-correlation, I started gotten a, first b, first c,
first d, first e, first f, first and then g, h, and i.
And that's how I actually did the looping and how I got the result.
And now let's look at this example, now my k is minus 1, but
minus, minus becomes 1, so basically the first element I pick up
in convolution would be this 1, okay.
And the second one I would pick up would be this one,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Here in this case for this instance, I started with first.
Then traversing it this way, and traversing it this way.
In case of convolution, untraversing it.
In essence, by just changing the sign here,
I've actually now given myself the ability to the flip, before I do anything.
And that's important part on what we want to actually do.
And that was a difference by just changing this no, sign here allows us to do.
So in essence that's how we're able to get this completely flipped kernel.